uh my question is for
okay so my question is for
uh ustaff
muhammad hijab so
um a lot of your da'awa is
you know
exposing the liberal agenda you know
from the west and so on and how it's
creeping into uh families and destroying
families and destroying cultures
and um in nigeria i think it's still
at an earlier stage as it might be in
the west maybe like the uk or the us so
um
what do you think we should start to do
now in nigeria whereby it hasn't reached
the stage whereby it's
irreversible what can we do to lip it in
the body so it doesn't you know
infiltrate our culture and our religion
here in nigeria so what do you think we
can do what steps do you think we can
take in order to repeat in the board
next questions you had the first
question there's another question again
talking about the hairstyle for a male
muslim how does it go
as for the first question about
liberalism
before
in the west and when i say the west i'm
talking about
england
france
germany
and its extensions like the united
states of america
in the west the religions that used to
be very popular
was christianity
now
in the country wherein which i live
which is the uk
the majority of people are not christian
anymore
this is a very important point
you will know that christianity came
into nigeria
through colonialism
when the missionaries came into nigeria
in the early 1900s
and they sometimes pushed the agenda of
christianity
it is ironic now
that the white man came into the country
taught people christianity
but now has left it himself
you see this point
the white man has left 40 percent
the census data in 2021
in the uk
says 40 percent
the estimates are 40 of people will be
christian in the uk which is the
majority of people are not christian
they are
non-religious the same thing can be said
in other countries in europe
instead
in the west now you have ideologies
you don't have religions as the main
ideas now you have ideologies
and the ideology of the west is called
liberalism
it is the main ideology
now it has replaced religion in the west
liberalism basically states
that we are the most important thing
and it says
you can do whatever you want so long as
you don't harm anybody else that's what
they say
so when we talk about homosexuality
a man having intercourse with another
man and having a relationship with
another man or a woman
having a relationship with another woman
they say this is okay this is fine
and they say this is okay and this is
fine because they are not harming
anybody else
don't get into their business leave them
alone this is what they say
i have had discussions which you can
find online
with many of them
and ask them questions
for example
i say to them
what do you say
of a situation where a brother and a
sister are in the relationship together
brother and sister
so long as they don't harm anybody else
the brother can use condom or something
sorry to say sorry to be explicit
they say this is very bad this is very
wrong
i say but this is what your principle
says
you said you can do whatever you like so
long as you don't harm anybody else
so homosexuality
the idea of a man being in a
relationship with another man
is a kin or the same or comparative to
a brother being in a relationship with a
sister
they don't want to accept the difference
so what you do like anything
is you show
that rationally their new ideologies
don't make sense
for example now you have people
that say there are men and they are
actually born as women
they have an xx chromosome
and they say they are men
or women who are men are born over xy
chromosome with a penis sorry to say
they say they are
women
in fact i heard there's somebody in
nigeria now called bob briskey or
something like that i'm sure many of you
know what i'm talking about
he's like this yeah i've heard that i
mean you can correct me if i'm wrong
now
this is
something which doesn't make scientific
sense
it doesn't make sense
they make the white man and the western
world makes fun of
the easterners
they say
look what these people are doing they
believe in mythologies they believe in
gods and voodoo and all of this
but the white man now and the west
they believe in mythologies what is a
mythology something which is against the
reality
something which is a story a narrative
which is
not true
when a man says i'm a woman or woman
says i'm a man
this is a form of myth religion
so we need to teach our children
that the western people and the white
man
now has a new kind of mythology
and they want to
force us to believe it but in a
different way
a hundred years ago
they gave us no choice they came into
africa
and they they pointed the guns at us
simple as that they had more guns they
pointed the guns at us and they said
this is we're coming to civilize you
it's what they said before
now
they're not doing it that way because
they realize that's a very difficult way
so the way they are doing it is through
netflix through youtube
through movies
through series
and somebody watching something online
and they're attracted to western
ideology
the reason why they're attracted to it
is because they think the white man is
always right
that's what they think
that's what people think
whether they're asian people or african
people or arab people because the white
man has the biggest guns and the
cleanest streets and the tallest
buildings
we think that they must be right in
everything else
but this is not true because this is
something which they have no evidence
for
so we bring the matter back to an
evidence discussion
we bring the matter back to an evidence
just like we did with christianity we
showed them that christianity is false
now they agree with us
they most of them now in the west say
yes we agree christianity is wrong
now they are saying this
we're saying now you are wrong again
just because you have tall buildings in
your cities
which you only have because you took our
wealth from our countries africa and
asia and these places you only have
those two and clean buildings because of
that it doesn't mean you're right about
morality
that's a false understanding
one of their scholars his name was carl
young
he said something very interesting
he said that the west
are technological giants
and moral dwarfs
they have very limited morality
in some western countries you can have
sex with a dog
it's
legal for you to have intercourse with a
with an animal with a dog
yes
i have debated professors in the west
and they said yes you can have sex with
a dog
they agreed with that i said how is the
dog going to tell you whether he wants
to have sex with you or not
what does the dog have to do
and so they haven't got questions for
these they haven't got answers for these
questions their morality is defunct
and we need to have self-respect and
realize that we're upon the truth
we have to be confident with the truth
of islam
their ideas keep changing our ideas have
remained the same actually
and so
the first step is to recognize the
problem
there is a problem
where because we've been colonized so
many times before we think whatever the
white man says it must be right
we have to accept this some people have
this not everybody but some people have
this idea
the second thing is to realize that
their ideas have been wrong before and
they've changed their mind before
number three
is then to realize that let's bring it
back to an evidence discussion
what they are saying
is not in line with scientific or
rational evidence
therefore we say
if we do this if we start the process
from now
then when they come in with their
agendas
through education system or through this
or through that whatever it may be we
can already have the
ability to
to